لنستعرض معكم مشاهدينا حجم المساعدات التي
قدمتها الولايات المتحده الى اوكرانيا منذ
بدء الحرب والتي تجاوزت 24 مليار دولار من
بين هذا خائر مدفعيه وذخائر لانظمه صواريخ
سام للدفاع الجوي وانظمه هذه التي شكلت
فريقا في الحرب بينما يستعد الكونجرس
لاقرار مشروع قانون الميزانيه العامه
للدوله الفيدراليه والذي يتضمن مساعدات
جديده لاوكرانيا تبلغ قيمتها
44.9 مليار دولار ارقام ضخمه لحرب قد تعيد
رسم خريطه المنطقه اذا الدعم الغربي لكاف
كان عاملا حاسما وبطبيعه الحال تصدرت
قائمه الداعمين الولايات المتحده مع 19.6
مليار دولار قدمت على شكل معدات واسلحه
عسكريه واربع فاصل 6 مليار دولار مساعدات
ماليه عسكريه ليبلغ
المساعدات حتى الان 24 فاصل اثنين مليار
دولار ابرز الاسلحه الامريكيه كانت انظمه
هايمرز ومدافع الهوتجر وصواريخ جافلن
المحموله على الكتف اضافه الى كميه ضخمه
من الذخائر المتنوعه بريطانيا حلت ثانيه
في قائمه الزعيمين مع تقديمها مع الداتا
واسلحه بقيمه مليارا دولار اضافه الى
اثنين فاصل ثلاثه مليار دولار كمساعدات
ماليه عسكريه باجمالي بلغ اربعه فاصل
ثلاثه مليار دولار بينها مدافعها وصواريخ
جافنن اما المانيا فقدمت اثنين فاصل اربعه
مليار دولار كم عداد واسلحه تضمنت مدرعات
المانيه وصواريخ سنجر المحمول على الكتف
امريكا السرعه
الجاره بولندا بحجم المساعدات قدمت
مساعدات قدرت بمائه او 1.9 مليار دولار
اسلحه ومعدات عسكريه مثل ما ذكرنا اضافه
الى اسهامات اخرى من كندا و انروج وسوايد
والدمرك واتشيك اما فرنسا في حلت بالمرتبه
الاخيره مع تقديمها نصف مليار دولار معدات
عسكريه واسلحه فقط وذلك بسبب تخوف رئيسها
ايمانويل من اهانه روسيا وفقا